kolumbien brennt demonstranten und
staatsmacht stehen einander
unversöhnlich gegenüber immer wieder
eskaliert die gewalt
dutzende junger menschen sterben durch
die kugeln der sicherheitskräfte durch
entschluss in den kopf zerstören sie
unsere träume und das recht auf ein
würdiges leben
seit wochen demonstrieren die
kolumbianer sie sind frustriert und
wütend auf die regierung weil sie sich
um ihre zukunft betrogen fühlen wenn es
nötig ist kämpfen wir bis zum tod
wir werden sie was braucht es um ein
polizist zu sein
man muss einen [ __ ] seien tag und
nacht ist es mutig oder leichtsinnig die
schwer bewaffnete kolumbianische polizei
aus nächster nähe zu beleidigen
für alexandra ist es vor allem die wut
ein polizist tötete ihren sohn dylan per
kopfschuss als dieser für eine bessere
bildungspolitik demonstriert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das einzige was ich empfinde ist schmerz
deshalb kann ich nicht darüber
nachdenken ob die polizisten auch
familie haben oder was sie empfinden
alexandra wurde zum sprachrohr
hunderttausend kolumbianer weil ihr sohn
dylan zu einem märtyrer der
protestbewegung wurde
[Applaus]
er hat seine stimme erhoben für seine
rechte für sein recht auf bildung und
deshalb bin ich hier weil sie ihn
ermordet haben
alexandras wut leidenschaft und
furchtlosigkeit inspirieren auch andere
demonstranten
und so ist sie zu einer art berühmtheit
geworden auf den straßen von bogotá
immer wieder wird sie erkannt
demonstranten drückten ihr beileid und
ihre unterstützung aus oder wollen
einfach nur auf ein foto mit ihr
[Musik]
seit wochen über zieht eine welle des
protestes kolumbien was mit
demonstrationen gegen eine inzwischen
zurückgezogene steuerreform begann hat
sich zu einer grundsätzlichen abrechnung
mit dem staat entwickelt es sind junge
menschen studenten aber auch familien
aus der mittelschicht die sich abgehängt
und unterdrückt fühlen von einer reichen
weißen elite die seit jahrzehnten
kolumbien beherrscht ich protestiere
wegen über 50 jahren in denen die
repräsentanten im kongress und senat die
präsidentin immer die gleichen waren die
väter dann die söhne und dann die söhne
der söhne es ist vor allem dieses gefühl
der ohnmacht dass bei so vielen
demonstranten für wut sorgt sie fühlen
sich gefesselt erstickt unterdrückt von
einem staat der ihnen die chancen auf
eine bessere zukunft und es ist ein
schrei der verzweiflung der frustration
vonseiten einer jugend die weder arbeit
findet noch bildungschancen
wir nennen sie die weder noch generation
viele die protestieren haben weder einen
festen job noch studieren sie es gibt
leute die keine zukunft
nach außen präsentiert sich kolumbien
als modernes politisch und vor allem
wirtschaftlich liberales land
doch es ist tief gespalten nach dem
historischen friedensschluss von 2016
zwischen der linksgerichteten
farc-guerilla und der regierung sollten
50 jahre bürgerkrieg beendet werden und
ein neues zeitalter beginnt
doch bis heute ist der frieden mehr als
brüchig
gewaltsame auseinandersetzungen morde
vertreibungen gehören weiter zum alltag
in teilen kolumbiens
[Musik]
kritiker werfen vor allem präsident
dunkel vor den friedensprozess nicht
ausreichend zu unterstützen
und es scheint dass diese geschichte der
gewalt bis heute das verhalten der
staatsmacht prägt die die aktuellen
proteste häufig als direkten angriff auf
den staat interpretiert dutzende
demonstranten wurden allein in den
letzten wochen von sicherheitskräften
getötet die regierung aber rechtfertigt
das harte vorgehen
man würde sich lediglich viren gegen
randalierer und kriminelle
diese reaktion hat ihre wurzeln in der
mangelhaften fähigkeit und der
mangelnden bereitschaft zu verstehen was
vor sich gehen es ist eine antwort die
für eine schwache regierung typisch ist
sie greift auf waffen doch die
verfolgung der proteste zurück als
einzige instrumente die sie hat um mit
dem was passiert umzugehen
wir sind zu hause bei alle hand der
mutter des getöteten
sie teilt sich eine kleine wohnung mit
zwei töchtern und ihrem vater ihr sohn
dylan war 18 jahre alt als er erschossen
wurde und ging noch zur schule
später wollte er psychologie studieren
er war ein ganz normaler junge wie jeder
andere
gegen den mutmaßlichen schützen einem
mitglied einer spezialeinheit der
polizei wird wegen mordes ermittelt
der prozess hat jedoch noch nicht
begonnen
[Musik]
wie kann es sein dass man seine kinder
großzieht sie sagt sie mit aller kraft
unterstützt nur damit dann ein
unterdrücker und mörder stadt kommt und
sie von einem auf den anderen tag tötet
und noch dazu keine antworten gibt
unsere rechte können nicht mit blut
weggespült werden steht auf dem plakat
das sie gemalt haben
alexandra verdient ihr geld als straßen
verkäuferin mein leben von der hand in
den mund wie bei so vielen kolumbianern
wenigstens ihren kindern sollte es
einmal besser gehen sagt sie
doch seit jahren wächst die armut im
land und die korona pandemie hat die
lage noch verschärft wir leben in einem
land in dem es keine chancen gibt nichts
gar nichts
deshalb gehen die leute auf die straße
und was sagt die regierung dass sie
randalierer sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die musik vom volk der musik war schon
da lange bevor die spanischen eroberer
kamen und auf ihrem land eine kolonie
das spätere kolumbien errichteten bis
heute sehen die indigenen völker ihre
kultur und ihre gebiete bedroht durch
einen staat von dem sie sich nicht
verstanden und nicht respektiert fühlen
die allgemeine protestwelle hat auch sie
ermutigt in die städte zu ziehen um zu
demonstrieren
auch samuel macht mit er ist 27 jahre
alt
vor einigen jahren hat er sein dorf
verlassen um hier in bogota
elektrotechnik zu studieren um wie er
sagt sich das wissen anzueignen das
seinem volk ermöglichen soll
in diesem system zu überleben er muss
sich anpassen an ein system das den
indigenen fremd geblieben ist und
stattdessen spanischen eroberern
denkmäler sitzt
wir haben hier ihre monumente die wie
heilige orte behandelt werden und das
sollte nicht so sein
sie haben das nicht verdient sie haben
uns verletzt menschen umgebracht und sie
haben uns eine kultur aufgezwungen die
nicht unsere ist eine europäische kultur
immer wieder bringen indigene gruppen
und andere demonstranten in ganz
kolumbien statuen spanische eroberer
zufall wie hier die des konquistadoren
sebastian dibelka sei ein symbolischer
akt war zum beispiel eine statue zu fall
zu bringen die uns nicht repräsentiert
das war eine statue die zu ehren von
jemandem errichtet worden ist der uns
massakriert hat der unsere vorfahren so
sehr massakriert hat als er jäger
abends versammeln sich die mieter in
lagern an den plätzen der stadt ihre
lebensweise dreht sich um die
gemeinschaft aller und so wird auch hier
gemeinsam gegessen getanzt und
protestiert
das ist der kampf lateinamerikas lasst
uns diesen orten eine neue bedeutung
geben damit hier nicht nur monumente
stehen sondern sie zum ausdruck
kultureller diversität werden zum
ausdruck unterschiedlicher meinungen
werden
[Applaus]
auch samuel ist regelmäßig dabei er
sucht den austausch mit den angehörigen
seines volkes ihre traditionen reichen
jahrhunderte zurück doch das sogenannte
moderne kolumbien und die indigenen
völker sind einander fremd geblieben
die kultur und territorien der indigenen
völker genießen gesetzlichen schutz
doch sie geraten immer stärker unter
druck sei es durch bergbau und
ölkonzerne missionare oder andere
interessengruppen
wir tun uns zusammen um zu sagen dass
das kapitalistische system uns leid
zufügt es bewahrt die mutter erde nicht
die umwelt das wasser die lebensweise
der menschen
es macht uns zu individualisten zusammen
mit anderen mieter klebt samuel in einem
studentenwohnheim die anpassung an die
großstadt fällt ihm schwer
er vermisst seine heimat das einfache
leben in und von der natur in der stadt
holt man sich das essen aus dem
kühlschrank und nicht aus der erde
es ist schwierig so zu leben aber man
riskiert es weil man weiterkommen will
weil man gut ausgebildet sein will auch
an die kleidung in der stadt musste
samuel sich gewöhnen jeans und hemd
trägt er in seinem heimatdorf kaum in
seinem zimmer zeigt er uns sein
traditionelles gewand
wir männer tragen einen schal und legen
uns danach einen rocker in etwa so aber
zur demonstration nämlich den rock nicht
mit aus sicherheitsgründen
es kann sein dass sich vor der
spezialeinheit der polizei weg laufen
muss und so könnte ich ihn verlieren
samuel konnte einen studienplatz an
einer öffentlichen universität ergattern
doch die sind knapp
und private schulen und unis können sich
die wenigsten leisten
dabei sei bildung die voraussetzung für
ein selbstbestimmtes leben sagt er und
der erschwerte zugang zu ihr ein mittel
staatlicher unterdrückung
deshalb fordern wir dass bildung
kostenlos ist das anerkannt wird dass
kolumbien ein multikulturelles land ist
das wurde seit jahren nicht anerkannt
für uns indigene gemeinschaften ist es
hier in kolumbien als würden wir nicht
existieren
samuel hat sich an das leben in der
stadt angepasst
trotzdem wünscht er sich dass die
lebensweise der indigenen völker
respektiert wird und sie die
gleichberechtigte bürger behandelt
werden
sie fordern die anerkennung ein dass
auch sie bürger dieser gesellschaft sind
mit vollen rechten keine bürger die man
in rosien ausstellt mit folkloristischer
kleidung denn dass es der erlaubten und
nicht der mit indigener identität
die hängt zusammen mit einem eigenen
verständnis von produktion und wicklung
erhaltung mit einem anderen verständnis
von nachhaltig den ungehörten und den
brutal zum schweigen gebrachten eine
stimme zu geben es zum lebensinhalt von
alessandra geworden
ich schulde es meinem sohn dylan sagt
sie mit ihrer aus dem schmerz geborenen
energie bewegt sie tausende andere wir
kämpfen dafür dass sie unsere
jugendlichen unsere studenten nicht
weiter morgen wie lang für immer bis
wann bis zum sieg und wenn es nötig ist
bis zum tod
wir werden siegen
[Applaus]
doch wenn die rufe verhallt sind kehrt
die stille zurück und die trauer wird
wieder laut und so kehrt alexandra immer
wieder an den ort zurück an dem ihr kind
genommen wurde durch eine kugel der
polizei wenn er hier wäre würde er sich
sicher auf der einen seite stolz fühlen
zu sehen was er für die jungen menschen
bedeutet und auf der anderen seite wäre
er sehr traurig weil er sehen würde wie
vor schmerz ich empfinde
denn er wollte nichts schlechtes völlig
er wollte nicht dass ich leide
denn welche mutter suchte sich schon aus
die mutter eines märtyrers zu sehen
[Musik]